so I want to be smiling all at you but
the lights are very bright up there so
I'm just squinting at you so forgive me
um in a moment I'm going to ask you in
fact now I'm going to ask you now uh
when I give my talks I like to get a
photograph a reminder that everyone's
happy uh so I get that at the beginning
of the talk before the end of the talk
and maybe you've switched off so I'm
going to ask for smiling happy waving
hands and faces at me and then I can put
this on my blog afterwards so please
hands up and wave say hello excellent
brilliant
that's great thank you very much
all right nice uh so uh I'm talking
about uh successful data science
projects
um lessons from 20 years of my career uh
trying to find ways that I failed so you
don't need to fail uh and some successes
in there as well and we end on a nice
positive note uh with a recent story uh
right so
why do I care about this well it turns
out after 20 years of working in the in
data science in general
um I really care about seeing smart
people do interesting things and have a
have a good job a good good work in
Academia doing well with their lives I
get really frustrated when I see people
doing things that just don't pan out for
all sorts of reasons and I've done
plenty of things that haven't panned out
and it's incredibly frustrating and most
of us don't like talking about our
failures I've got a newsletter I'll put
a link up for that at the end and I'm
talking about successes and failures
that I've had and the lessons that come
out of it and then when I've been
talking about some of the successes at
one point one of my readers Ricardo came
back and said hey and it's lovely to
hear these positive lessons and we can
learn a lot from the positive lessons
but what about when things aren't
working so well I thought well actually
got this keynote coming up for pi data
Budapest maybe I should talk about some
of the failures so I'm telling a version
of this that same story uh here so I was
very happy to uh to be prompted to talk
about the failures in one's career
rather than just the successes
so who am I uh so I'm an interim Chief
data scientist so I run my own company I
go into companies previously I used to
go and write the intellectual property
so I'd go and solve problems for
companies uh doing all of our classic
data science work I still do a bunch of
that but typically now I go in and I
help teams to succeed so I help the
teams to figure out how to write the
right stuff particularly get the teams
to think about asking the right
questions not the question they were
asked to solve but maybe the other
question the one that's actually
valuable to the organization which maybe
doesn't require any big solution maybe
just requires some so asking some
sensible numeric questions about how
things are working but let's ask the
right thing and then use data science as
a technique if that's the right
technique to go and do it and I love
doing my machine learning I love
diagnosing and I I've written a book
with O'Reilly second edition high
performance python I love my high
performance I've got a course on that I
love talking about that I've got a
course on successful data science
projects so lessons from my career on
how not to fail and I've taken a bunch
of those lessons to put in here because
I love talking about this stuff so I am
still technical but I see so much more
we can get value out of what we do by
thinking more as Dylan was saying in the
previous talk thinking more about what
the business needs what the real
objectives are behind the uh the problem
that we're solving and one of the
founders of Pi data London here so eight
years ago I think it was eight years ago
we had our first conference and it's
grown up to this wonderful event and
even with our two-year break uh we've
still got a wonderful turnout here which
is brilliant thank you very much for all
coming along uh please remember to go
and thank your speakers and the sponsors
and the volunteers and the non-focused
staff because it's all volunteer time
that brings this all together
um and then I help from the the meet up
with our 11 000 members you're super
welcome to come along and join that as
well of course
uh and uh some of the client names at
the top yeah they're clients that I've
worked with they're not the clients
featured in the stories that follow I've
protected uh the guilty afterwards so uh
how does data science work in
organizations
um some of you may have come across the
underpant gnome sketch uh from South
Park uh so Cartman and others have
discovered that someone's stealing their
underpants uh they're not really sure
what's going on they track down the
underpant nodes and they say what are
you doing why are you stealing our
Underpants and they don't say well we're
collecting Underpants and then we're
going to profit brilliant how do you
profit well and then it all gets
confused that's a big question mark in
the Medline it's a classic hack and use
Trope do something question mark
question mark question mark profit and I
think in data science so we get to this
thing where well look we just we've got
this data science problem someone's told
us to do the data science we're going to
go and get the data and then we're going
to deep neural net the big data and do
the data science and we're going to
profit at the end of it and it's going
to be glorious but I suspect that
actually a lot of the time when things
don't work out uh it's because we've
asked the wrong question we've thought
about this the wrong way and so here
I'll tell a couple of stories where I've
thought about things the wrong way or
things have worked out the wrong way and
then I'll give you a reflection on this
at the end
so I think we fail a lot I know I failed
a lot it was difficult to say that right
I'm a consultant I shouldn't fail I
should always succeed for my clients but
I think we all fail a lot so I'm going
to ask that uh how many of you have been
Associated during your career with at
least one project failure
okay so all of you brilliant keep your
hands up if it's at least two project
failures
okay so most of the hands do right so
great we've established that we all fail
brilliant so we're all failures
excellent uh when I've had more than two
um
I've been doing this for 20 years you
collect all of those War Stories over
time and you realize actually there's a
bunch of reasons why some of these
things evolve but we don't talk about
failure very much
um this is one of three talks out of 40
at the conference talking about the
non-data science statistics machine
learning mlops side of things so it's
less than 10 of the conferences looking
at this but this is the thing that gives
you the project that's worth a million
or not a million if you get it wrong so
I think this is an increasingly
important topic to talk about talk about
so I'm super Keen to talk about it
afterwards if you want so I think it's
not all about the technology of course
the tech is important of course the
stats is important but I think it's not
all about that I think there's a lot of
human factors that come into this that
cause things to go wrong at various
stages and a lot of them are easy to
learn from and you don't have to repeat
my mistakes brilliant you can take some
easy lessons
so let's uh wind back in time this is
very early in my career
this goes back uh
15 years
13 years quite a long time ago
I had a client they were doing uh
automated price discovery of products
online so that when you visited a retail
store in your browser and you found a
product they could tell you the same
product was cheaper elsewhere and they
get an affiliate fee from directing you
there very sensible thing this is when
Amazon wasn't quite the behemost that it
is now and there were many alternate
sites to go and buy or things from
Amazon was one of the players for sure
so you take some metadata from lots of
sites about the same television or
lipstick or deodorant or white good for
your kitchen whatever it was huge data
set and then do some natural language
processing
um and 15 years ago NLP wasn't quite so
well written about as it is now you
couldn't just go to medium or stack
Overflow and find the answers of how to
do this psychic learn is 13 years old
and I was using it so it was at least it
was about I don't know 12 11 years ago
so back when we didn't know how to do
really good
NLP on our data science problems we had
to figure a bunch of this out as I went
um we had to go and we our little team
had to go and figure out how to find the
most similar products because every
website has a different version of that
product they spell it differently
describe it differently they've got two
descriptions up there
so you want to find the cheapest one
great
I talked to the client this is the
problem we agreed the specification
verbally first mistake I shouldn't have
done that should have written it down so
we agreed a specification verbal it made
sense small tight team working together
collaborating we all knew what the
problem was
um I got them to spell out exactly what
the problem was what the data was how
this was all going to fit together so
that we couldn't make a mistake very
important not to make a mistake
um and so I built up a gold validation
set explained to them the importance of
having a gold standard we could work
against before we went on to a larger
data set built our bag of words model
using scikit-learn then our similarity
measures all pretty sensible stuff and
we made great progress everything was
looking pretty good so what could go
wrong this is one of my early solo
consultant projects it's all going
gloriously brilliant
then they gave you some more data and it
was weird data and we know enough about
NLP now that whenever you scrape data
off the world we get all of the horrible
stuff we get
um strange
um uh different Windows versus utf-8
encoding as a text we get misspellings
uh we get strange punctuation we get
slash ends we get zeros and O's confused
and we just get all of the rubbish that
you get off the web fine
The Annoying Thing was the client hadn't
told me about this and when I said to
them look we've got this new weird data
set that's quite different in nature to
the previous one even though we've
agreed to solve this one problem uh why
has it changed now but oh well
we didn't want to scare you off with the
hard data set so although we gave you
the one data set actually there's two
data sets and now we're showing you the
real problem I thought oh that's that's
kind of crap right because we can't
solve this problem how does the human
solve this oh the human can't solve this
we can't we can't actually figure this
out the data's awful but your data
science magic no no data science magic
I'm gonna have to walk out of here now
and so that was really upsetting um even
though I tried my hardest to make my
client explain to me what their problem
was they St they told me they told me
all of the problem but they still
segmented it into two and then gave me
another problem later when I proved the
first bit
which is nuts we could have figured out
the beginning that we couldn't solve the
hard problem and just not done the thing
in the first place
um so that's really painful that's bad
news we don't want to be doing that the
critical point there is we gained a lot
of knowledge but there was only one
project to work on we couldn't take that
knowledge and pivot to another project
and then reuse what we learned the hard
lessons we'd learned we had one thing it
failed end of deal and that was it
um so if you've got nowhere to Pivot to
that's bad news I've worked in well
we'll see on some other slides when
you've got options to Pivot you have
some options
what's an easy solution here we'll write
a specification okay if the client's
still not going to reveal the problem to
you you've got a bigger problem but at
least if you've got the thing written
down you've talked about it you've
expressed it you've had managerial sign
off but you've written everything down
I've got my examples nothing has been
hidden from me and you get everyone to
agree this is the entire problem
um then and you've had a human explain
how they solve every step of the problem
on all of the data that you've been
provided with you're probably okay so
when I teach my success class I get a
specification like this and we talk
through it and there's nothing super
magic in there's a bunch of topics that
you'd all agree look pretty sensible you
haven't got to use all of them what is
the business need that's going on here
what is the dollar value behind the
business need do we understand why the
business makes money or saves time or
whatever it is
um who has the responsibilities where
does the data come from what are the
uncertainties in the data what risks
might I see in there uh what assumptions
can I make what would the timeline look
like it's all boring stuffer I'm not
solving any machine learning with this
but if I go and ask these kind of
questions I flush out so many
uncertainties and then my project runs
more smoothly and is less likely to
explode so that's easy we just write
stuff down by asking some simple
questions so that's one lesson
here's another lesson uh so another
story
um I did I've done a bunch of work in
insurance now over the years I really
enjoy working in Insurance interesting
industry uh you think it's pretty
sophisticated but typically Insurance
organizations they're very risk-averse
they're quite conservatives they're not
sophisticated some of the biggest ones
are they've got very nice data science
teams uh the tier two tier threes well
they've got data science and they've got
data and then the smallest ones
definitely not they've got Excel and
some old data and that's about it but
it's an industry that needs to get more
efficient and better understanding of
its data and it's it's customers its
needs its evolving Market
uh so I was working in a team um I
joined when it was 10 and we got up to
25 or so across a couple of continents
uh revolutionizing one of the large
insurers brilliant
um there was a difficulty here we had a
boss who had a very very hard challenge
he had to go and get large chunks of the
business aligned with the needs of data
science when everybody didn't want data
science they wanted to be conservative
and do the same old thing without taking
the risks because risks mean failure and
then a non-risk friendly atmosphere
that's bad news so he sold success
he sold success before he'd seen the
data he'd sold success before he'd seen
whether the business recorded the data
that you needed to solve the things that
were sold as success so we as the data
scientists were given projects this will
generate a million dollars this year for
that client on that vertical go and
solve it I think brilliant where's the
data you can't find it it'll be over
there somewhere in Excel or something
and some of the times there was data and
some of the times there was good data
and you could actually build models that
outperforms the Actuarial models and we
made money brilliant and a lot of times
there wasn't data one of my glorious
projects involved several months tracing
it back to the point where we discovered
yeah the reason why the data's not in
the database is not because nobody even
types it in it's because nobody scanned
the paper document that stored in an
off-site facility but you do data
science right you can use the magic to
get that data off the paper that's over
there somewhere and do something with it
and no of course you can't
um and then bringing that organization
along that journey to realize that
actually you are backward and you've got
to upskill data storage putting things
in a database making sure the data is
there that's just the long painful
Journey but when you've been told you're
delivering a million in three months
because that's been signed off already
before you even got involved in the
project it's kind of terrifying but it
was an upside unlike the previous client
engagement where I only had the one
option here we had multiple problems in
multiple departments and multiple
verticals lots of different
opportunities to Pivot so even though
some of the projects didn't work we
learned a lot about how to solve these
problems and who had good data who
didn't have good data in this large
organization whether they'd have lived
who was collaborative who put resources
up front and so we could pivot around
and then we got more success that way so
another lesson here would be always look
for opportunities to Pivot and if you
can't find pivot opportunities and
there's some high risks be really wary
about wading into that could be really
exciting until it goes horrible around
you so try not to be in that that
position
and then talk to the client talk to the
humans in the organization I spend so
much of my time teaching data science
teams to go and talk to the humans
elsewhere in the business because they
know what their problem is they know if
they're recording the data that they
need to actually automate any of these
solutions they know if they don't bother
typing in the data or if they Outsource
it to someone who types it indifferently
every month because it goes out to the
cheapest organization that will do this
outsourced work they know what's
feasible they know what the actual
dollar value is behind all of this so go
and encourage your teams and yourself go
and talk to the business and find out
what we can do with all of this and if
people are really reticent about
committing that hey you could automate
anything with the data that we've got
don't commit to doing a project I've
learned that one sadly a couple of times
because I'm always optimistic I always
try to be so optimistic with my clients
and then it turns out sometimes you just
get beaten around the hill with a stick
a few times before you realize if the
client if the if the people who have the
data if they're not optimistic about it
well probably there's nothing there that
you can actually operate on as a data
scientist
in my course I talk about the data
maturity model I think this is a pretty
interesting way of thinking about
organizations it applies some startups
through to the the largest organizations
so and there are many data maturity
models out there this one's quite nice
because it's just got four simple
pillars growing up that maturity stack
is difficult
so if you've got a data apathetic
organization I will never touch a data
apathetic organization they haven't
recorded their data they don't use Excel
very much they haven't written things
down it's all in people's heads there's
no data you can't do any science there
no data no data science
a data-driven organization does pretty
much everything by the data that they've
got stored brilliant Excellence to the
Man Group here with their automated
trading strategies one of our sponsors
that's an example of that data-driven
organization that means they've solved a
lot of their problems already and
they've got all the data they need
brilliant they're in a very mature
position
I quite like working with the data aware
and the data critical places because
that's where teams are coming online
they're getting their data together they
do have data or they've built teams but
they fail to deliver a lot and then I
can help them unlock a bunch of that and
that's really interesting to me and I
found working in organizations As you
move between different departments
taking data science as a siled activity
perhaps out to different teams some
teams well actually they're they're
critical already they've got all their
data they're making decisions they want
faster results better prediction others
are less less sophisticated as long as
you've got a way of judging that and
you're going to think about what I do
with it and can I help this team do they
have what I need so that we can move
forwards in a sensible way that's a good
mental model to have
here's another example from insurance
with one of the teams that we worked
with and this is one of the successful
projects in that previous organization
that I mentioned they had the data it
was brilliant it was doing this my
colleague was doing the same thing as I
was doing I had a project where no one
was even scanning the data from Bits of
Paper he had a project where the data
was beautiful it was in the database it
was time stamped it went back years it
was consistent and clean it was
wonderful
he built a machine learning model on it
at random Forest it worked great so we
could actually outperform the existing
technology in the company we had metrics
to show that brilliant we took it to the
client the client was one of the
underwriters so they were not data
science oriented but they had a good
mathematical background and they didn't
trust this solution they didn't trust
this new data science team we hadn't
delivered all our output of value to the
organization yet so the trust was low
and my colleague bless him he was
drawing random Forest tree diagrams
printing them out and walking the
clients through a tree structure one
tree at a time explaining the value of
an ensemble and an average guest that
comes out of the Ensemble and trying to
walk them through all of the detail and
explaining it and it had some huge like
anal printouts showing these streets it
was a beautiful effort All Points there
for effort but I could watch my client
just switching off to thinking I'd have
no clue what this means and I do not
care and I don't trust this thing
uh and so we step back and we said well
hang on a minute so first of all rather
than explaining all of every single tree
how about the colleague and I just go
through some of the examples and we've
traced them back to their raw data
sources check it makes sense and
validate some of these for the client we
came back to the client and it turns out
there was some weirdness in there and
the client would say oh yeah that's
because that client's special they're in
the other table you do know about the
other table don't you say oh no we
didn't know about the other table great
so we're going iterate a couple of times
find all the other data sources and
improve the model and we improve the
data integration brilliant and we go
back with the clients and we start using
shap as one of the Diagnostics and just
explaining individual predictions they
would ask some pointed questions and
sometimes they go yeah I don't really
understand that judgment but it's you
know I kind of get where we are on the
positive negative scale and the factors
behind it that kind of makes sense then
they asked us this really hard question
about one of the examples they knew and
we brought it up and we talked about it
for a while and they went yeah
yeah okay I get it I trust it now that's
good I I that's my client and you've
explained it and the model explains it
the way I'd explain it so therefore I'd
trust this for everything let's just
deploy it and it was a beautiful moment
in trust winning it taken several weeks
to get there but having that visual
diagnostic process and going through the
raw data with the client discovering all
the bits that we've missed and going
round and round in a loop but really
figuring out what the client mistrusted
they didn't know what this black box was
doing and opening up that black box and
talking them through one step at a time
at a high level that they could
understand with a nice shapley diagram
was a really nice way to get them on
board with trust
we Segway sideways another one of my
clients who's working in Venture Capital
with one of the top tier venture
capitalist firms in the UK and they said
hey we want to investigate our data we
don't normally investigate it please
come and do some magic well we're not
doing that magic discussion I hate the
magic discussion
um partly because uh I don't know your
data and also I don't know VC so I'm
ignorant I don't know your business
domain
um let's talk about what you actually
need and where you want to go and so
let's do a de-risking project check the
quality of your data we identified many
issues of course they hadn't used their
data that's always a good proxy for and
my data is awful so the data was awful
we had to go and fix it up that shows no
progress to the clients that's a
difficult one to sell on but then you've
got to do that before you can do the
next thing of course and then we got to
build some models uh later on
um it's always good to stop your client
whenever they ask you to go and do some
magic and just say we're not doing magic
Magic's crap we're not doing that we
have to go and understand what we what
we've got but also what you need and Is
it feasible with the data that we've got
one of the nice things when you've got a
clean data set so that's the insurance
example and the Venture Capital example
is you can go in with Baseline models I
always go in with the simplest Baseline
model that we've got yesterday we had
the executives at Pi data session and
one of the uh one of the attendees was
talking about getting a model deployed
early on in the first couple of weeks
with a random guest in there so not a
model that's learned anything but just
getting a model process deployed that
makes a random guess so we can go
beginning to end and the thing works and
we can see it working super important
I'm massively behind that now and I've
had examples like in the insurance
industry months being spent on an
outsourced team building a random forest
model that was going to be amazing now
almost ever quite sure if this thing was
actually working and there were no
Diagnostics no I'm sure on the data but
we went through it and okay the code
kind of looked all right and it was it
was weird that months have been spent
and someone said yeah but if you take
the average of the data set you get less
error than if you use the machine
learned model on the same data set that
was a huge embarrassment and that led to
some arguments because with three months
invested the bosses wanted to politely
deploy the model and I would argue but
if we deploy the model that does worse
than just having a mean guest of the
data set the client's going to figure
that out right they're going to then not
trust us and we're a young team who
hasn't got many successes we can't
deploy a lie and that led to some
arguments
um and I it was just an awful way for
things to go
um flip that over to my Venture Capital
client and there they had a bunch of
rules that different members of the team
would use to evaluate their data to find
companies that looked interesting for
investment they have a very large set so
it's a prioritization problem
and they would say look my my uh my rule
is the best I've got several rules the
rank the right companies at the top and
everything else we discard and I could
Implement those rules using a bit of
numpy and a template using the template
classifier from scikit-learn and then
put that alongside a five-fold
cross-validation or a Time series cross
validation on the time series data set
against the logistic regression to input
model and show that my model outperforms
there's for various reasons and we could
build it up and that bought trust which
was really really nice so I massively
always argue for going with the pipeline
that does something first of all even if
it's a random guess and then start to
encode the clients rules and the clients
ways of thinking in us the next thing
and then going for a mean regressor or a
default classifier and then actually
beginning to do the data science
afterwards on top because that way
you're quickly showing incremental
progress all the way through and we've
got the tools for this in psychic learn
so it's really easy it's a couple of
lines of code you have to write and it's
often overlooked
The Venture Capital client did have a
downside that really didn't work out
quite so well one of my more painful
stories
um one thing I learned about venture
capital
is that when you've got 10 000 companies
uh coming in in Europe in a year that
need evaluation you've got a small team
evaluating them they want to find the 10
Investments they want to invest in so
it's a one on a one in one thousand uh
success rates are expecting to see there
and they want to reject all of the
others so they want to reject nine nine
thousand 9990 of these companies and
then just find the 10 that are good
first of all VC I learned it's a very
people-driven business no it's not in
the data they've got some data but the
interesting stuff is not in the data
it's in the the people's relationships
uh so that was bad news once we
discovered that but there is interesting
signal in some of the data and some of
the data is even consistent so actually
you can extract some of that statement
and do something with it
the people who go and make all the calls
and try to figure out which companies to
contact they're the junior associates
they are paid by success so they're
effectively High ticket sales people
Boutique sales people selling chunks of
five to fifty million pounds as an
investment in exchange for your equity
they get paid if they find the right one
or two companies to put that five to 50
million pounds into
so they do not want crazy Ian turning up
with some strange machine learning model
saying don't do it your way I've got
this new way that we don't trust the
tool that might reduce your chances of
finding your one or two down to zero or
one or maybe to zero but I need this for
you for your feedback rights and if I
get the feedback I can make this better
and one day you might get two or three
rather than one or two nobody wants to
make that first leap and particularly at
certain crunch points in the year like
Christmas well when they're trying to
close all the deals and that's when I
was doing my testing really trying to
push my testing out with the client so
that was really terrifying and I got my
contract got terminated there it's the
only contract that's ever been
terminated around me was really upset
about that I actually ran to the pub and
insisted my friends buy me beer that
night
um I got feedback from the CTO later on
that one of the deliveries I made was
used because it had one of the companies
listed highly that was a signal that
then went on to validate one of the
Investments they made so there was
positive outcome for the organization
but it turns out when you're in a
problem poor environment there's a very
little change answer success very little
relevant data and an organization not
using their data in that kind of fashion
already just the chance of success is
low
and I'm an optimist and I love a
difficult problem so of course I had to
go and try it but in terms of actually
doing well it was a silly thing to go
and do because it was really really hard
and it didn't really work out so again
try to avoid situations where when your
gut says actually it's just really
really hard walk away from that one go
and find a problem that's much easier
hopefully one where with some simple
rules you can go and get something of
value and then with a progression onto a
nice deep learning or whatever it's
going to be you can get an even better
result that's valuable for the company
but don't start with something that's
just really ridiculously hard don't make
that mistake please
so uh one of the ways to get past this
of course is to get your clients
involved early uh always be delivering
early and often again get that pipeline
going with the random guests are in
there that does something beginning to
end uh give them something that makes
them look cool
I found this to be very empowering I
haven't got to find the Insight that is
better than what the clients inside is
because the client is the person who
knows the business domain but they
haven't got an automated way of getting
that Insight out if I can encode a chart
a histogram uh whatever it is a table
that validates something that they know
they've never been able to prove to the
organization but I get the data I get
automatic buying at that point I get
more trust I get more flexibility to go
and do interesting things so help the
client look cool early on probably
that's pretty pictures that they can
show to their boss everyone is empowered
by pretty pictures I would always push
for that
um and then simple models linear models
you can always explain a linear model
with five terms for somebody and explain
which way the uh the coefficients are
going positive negative certain
magnitude there lots of pictures help
with the client to diagnose the problems
find the problems in the data that
builds trust because you've identified
those problems and then quickly deliver
some value to them so that they look
cool if we can do that we buy political
points we buy time for ourselves and
then we can go and do the cooler more
interesting hard work but that has to
come later
another uh Joy from the insurance
industry
um I wasn't working on this one
thankfully I just got to step to the
side of this and shake my head in shame
and one of my colleagues made a
successful random Forest a solution for
a machine learning problem great
um and then and this took some months
took a while to get the data to
understand the business domain to get by
and everything was good everything was
good everything was good and then it
said yeah we can't do python we need SQL
only so my colleague then by hand
re-roached the random Forest as best
they could in SQL as the deployment
strategy but there were no tests there
was no validation we hoped they
transposed the rules correctly as they
typed by hand we don't know so was it
right and that's that's awful
um and we could have well we could have
avoided that by just figuring out that
we had no deployment opportunity but
that's a silly deployment opportunity we
just shouldn't have done this product in
the first place but it's one of the
projects that was sold by the boss who
promised the big output and then we
because it had been promised we had to
go and deliver a thing and so it was
just painful all around and it wasn't
obvious at the end of it once it had
been deployed whether actually it was
working for the client then it was going
to use this thing and so always you know
can we actually gets to a deployed
status is there a question there
it's recently enough that it's still
painful In My Memory
um after the cloud that would presuppose
that the client was using a cloud
but that's presupposing that the client
had a cloud
right insurance industry conservative
likes boxes in a corner they can look at
and they do use the cloud sometimes
and some people are allowed to also use
the word cloud in conversations
sometimes but not everyone and certainly
not the data science teams and lots of
Industries are backwards right they're
they're quite conservative and then
getting everyone on board with what we
need for data science uh is hard in some
organizational lots of organizations
so what would be a solution here we'll
plan
um plan for operationalization and so
planning early for that especially for
your V1 in your specifications where
you're developing your plan with your
client think about what they would need
to deploy a solution and if it turns out
they've only got some weird vdu green
screen thing plumbed into a very Legacy
system with a Mainframe behind it and no
one knows how to integrate into it we do
not build a clever xgb model and hope
that we can superimpose the results onto
the screen because that's Madness we let
that department upskill itself over time
and come up with a modern system that we
can integrate with because otherwise we
cry
um so and also yeah sit with a client
figure out how they work now I've had so
much success by sitting with clients
watching them type details in and asking
them pointed questions about how do you
figure out which field you're choosing
there oh I just kind of guess at that
one all right I'm not going to use that
field uh why do you type into things
over here when the data's clearly over
there those systems are disconnected and
they often have duplicates or errors
between them okay I want data screwy
over there then but we only figure that
out by talking to the client and seeing
how they're operating
um and yeah don't forget I mean you all
know this but a corporate could take six
months just to get a machine before we
figured out what goes on to that machine
which is yeah More Tears so let's end on
our happy note um in the abstract I said
I'll tell a story about making a million
dollars for a client actually we had the
evaluation a couple of weeks ago and
conservatively optimistically we've
decided two million is actually what
we're delivering so we get to cross out
one minute and put two million up there
um for this recent climb which is
brilliant I'm really happy about this is
like one of my biggest best successes in
my career so I'm super happy about this
so I get to be enthusiastic now so this
is working in insurance I'm looking at
fraud and over billing so payments today
of duplicate invoices that are paid
because two invoices came in by mistake
or two invoices came in because somebody
decided to copy one and submit it again
and tried to commit fraud and then all
the weird and wonderful ways that this
branch is out
um lots of uh different interesting
things here there's a fraud team in the
company but they're hobbled by
non-automated tools so what can they do
with all this so what do we do we
de-risked early we spent a couple of
months discussing lots of project ideas
we found positive examples uh there
weren't many of those at the beginning
it inverted our ordering of potential
projects once we'd found those examples
the less interesting projects popped to
the top because we had examples and the
other ones we didn't we assigned values
so we could add to that prioritization
we agreed a delivery schedule based on
what we learned we had things like
improving the SQL debugging some SQL
super boring yeah we found a chunk of a
million there counting how many eye
tests do you have in a year you have one
or two you don't have 52 someone who has
lots of eye tests in the year is
probably doing fraud so we count no one
was counting this kind of thing
percentiles more nuanced version of
Counting lots of discussion with the
clients improving the SQL because we had
a problem-rich environment we had many
opportunities to go and exploit the
knowledge gained over here again over
here rinse and repeat an idea find more
value that was brilliant we did have
some machine learning in there great but
that wasn't the the thing that got us
the values and got the value was coming
up with those rules in the first place
and it got to the point where the boss's
boss was writing their own BI Solutions
to demonstrate new things that they saw
existed so that we could capitalize upon
those ideas so we've got a whole team
and layers of management brought into
this it was really really it's a
beautiful outcome I'm really really
happy with that uh but then we get a new
problem with that client uh it turns out
when you've got a tiny fraud team and
you're flooding them with new examples
of fraud because you've got automated
systems you've still got a small fraud
team so you've got to grow the fraud
team that'll take a couple of years so
moving up that data maturity model and
getting the organization mature enough
to use these things is how Burton takes
a lot of time
I've asked colleagues what they find
important for prioritizing projects and
dealing with new projects and new
clients and they give me rule sets like
these totally right a bit different from
mine you'll find that if you talk to
other seniors around what do you think
is most important everyone's got a
different set of these things but it
turns out find your seniors see what
rules have been encoded for your
organization and make sure you're asking
all of those questions and any of the
projects that you're working on that
gets you past so many of the problems
that you might face and so I think this
boils down to have a clear Rhythm
specification for your work before you
start try and de-risk as much as you can
know your business need and the value
and then Dylan was talking about that in
the previous talk coming up with good
business metrics incredibly important to
figure out actually if deep neural Nets
or machine learning or anything is
actually valuable in the first case know
the risks if your gut feels tight about
anything go and de-risk those risks
before you write any code don't do the
typey typey do the talky talkie go and
figure out what's going on because
otherwise you're going to waste time and
then it's all going to go horribly and
then know how to deploy it right at the
end
um before you start the project
so
I don't think we have to go and still
Underpants I think we have to go and
find good puzzles and think about the
whole puzzle set and a whole bunch of
that is human factors and then we solve
the puzzle deep learning neural Nets
machine learning stats might be in that
solve the puzzle piece but maybe not
maybe we're just solving a problem
that's easy to solve with some equations
in Excel and that's totally cool as well
and then we get the profit at the end of
it
so I'm talking about a whole bunch of
these things on my newsletter it's free
to join if you want to join in not a
number all the band pack logs up online
on that site so you can go and see the
stories that I've shared there if that's
of interest to you um I've got a bunch
of uh all of all of my past talks are on
my blog
um and if I've taught you anything
interesting I ask after every talk
please send me a postcard I have
physical postcards that I put on the
wall they're a physical reminder that
I've helped teach people something new
so that's interesting to you send me a
message I'll send you my uh my physical
mailing address and send me a postcard
I'd love a postcard they make me really
happy thank you very much for listening
[Applause]
thank you in that's great um we have
some time for questions please for a few
minutes
um
who's first sorry I haven't got my
glasses on are there any questions or
have I answered there we go
where you get to watch me run around the
room
Hi Ian thanks for the great talk
um what would be your advice for dealing
with like um moving Target problem in a
company so like Mike I have an example
for instance I'm sort of managing this
project and then I had to go away and
leave we had agreed on what we were
going to do then I had to go away and
then I came back there was a meeting
that happened to like talk about the
progress and so on and then suddenly the
specifications had changed because now
the client is like well actually I want
something else so like I'm trying to
like go back to what we had agreed and
so on so what would be your advice to
dealing with like changing
um expectations and goals all the time
and so on so that's really hard I mean
yeah the reason I write things down and
the reason I get Senior Management sign
off before we start anything is because
otherwise I'm the one left crying
because it would always come back to me
as the consultant you're the reason this
didn't work uh and if you did change
everything halfway through right yeah
but obviously
um so no I insist on a fixed
specification now the specification also
can be a living document and so we know
what we've what we think we want we know
what the metrics are we know what the
solution might be we know what the data
should be we know what the risks are and
then in my specification talk I'm happy
to be very happy to call it a living
document and iterate filling in the
blanks but the thing we want to deliver
is still the same thing that we want to
deliver and if someone changes their
mind there I'll say all right great
that's a new project let's start again
and you know do you want the cost of
starting a game
um and then that leads to some awkward
conversations but the alternative is I I
got it wrong and I've learned over 20
years I don't want to be the one getting
it wrong uh so yeah I would just say
you've got to dig in and say either
we're doing that project or we're
starting a new project which is totally
reasonable but we have to treat it as a
new project and we've learned a lot so
we can start it faster but it's the
learning project got to scope it de-risk
it a sign who's on it and all the rest
of it all again
it's that feasible yeah yeah okay
was there another question
oh that is five two
um
is that a quick question yeah okay there
we go
all right let's go Mike for the video oh
okay I was
so the question is
if you're in in our organization and the
data science team is currently
underutilized how what steps can you
take to sort of fix that
um
good question uh before I answer do we
need to swap the speaker yeah yeah yeah
so it's the next speaker here do you
want to come and step up whoever that is
are they in the room
um
so let me just unplug this
oh it's not that person oh
okay well they're not here um but I'll
answer that question then and just pull
right out there we go
um
how to use an underutilized data science
team great question uh walk around the
organization and learn what the business
is doing uh what's valuable and where
the problems are I tried to teach my
data scientists to go and talk to the
business in all the different
departments and just say what do you do
does it work
um what could be done better what
problems do you have and then after a
while those that are a bit more sociable
will come back with a laundry list of
problems many of them not interesting
for the data science team lots of
engineering technical whatever problems
or people problems lack of market share
problems whatever but then maybe you go
off to marketing or to sales and say hey
I've heard about these problems are
these interesting to you they go yeah we
do a b tests on these tiny groups and we
get these kind of noisy results back
that appear to be random
um and you go well that's because your
test set sizes are tiny
um how about I help you do a proper a B
test on a marketing split test with
appropriately sized groups and some
stats behind it and they go oh we never
did that sure and then you find a new
problem when you go and solve that and
so I think being adaptable is key there
but going off becoming internal
Consultants going around shopping
yourselves around finding problems and
finding valuable work for yourselves I
think it's an underrated activity as a
consultant I have to do it all the time
so I teach other data scientists yeah go
and do this you've got great skills to
sell it
thank you great question all right thank
you Ian um
so I'm going to step outside now if
anyone wants to carry on talking about
this please come outside and if you want
to carry on the exact conversation from
yesterday step outside and we'll carry
on thank you very much for having me